POPCORN BY A FAN ON HIS WAY OUT
THE ARENA.
HERE HE IS.
REPORTER: WHAT ABOUT THAT
INCIDENT WITH THE FAN?
RUSSELL: I DON'T KNOW BRO.
UNFORTUNATELY, I WAS LEAVING
OUT.
I SEEN POPCORN ON TOP OF MY
HEAD.
TO BE HONEST, THE STUFF IS
GETTING OUT OF HAND.
ESPECIALLY FOR ME.
JUST THE AMOUNT OF DISRESPECT
AND THE FANS JUST DOING WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
IT'S OUT OF POCKET MAN.
SERIOUSLY, ANY OTHER SETTING,
I'M ALL FOR THE FANS ENJOYING
THE GAME AND HAVING FUN.
I GET IT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
CROSS THE LINE.
ANY OTHER SETTING, I KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT FANS, THEY WANT TO
COME UP AND GUY WANT TO POUR
POPCORN ON MY HEAD.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
GUY COME UP TO ME AND TALK MESS
ABOUT MY KIDS AND FAMILY ON THE
STREET, THE RESPONSE WILL BE
DIFFERENT.
THESE ARENAS, YOU GOT TO PROTECT
THE PLAYERS.
WE'LL SEE WHAT THE NBA DOES.
FANS CAN SAY WHATEVER.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
UNTOUCHABLE.
THEY CAN SAY WHAT THEY WANT.
LOT OF TIMES FANS DON'T REALIZE,
THIS IS MY JOB.
THIS IS NOT SOME PLAY.
THIS IS SOMETHING I LOVE TO DO.
THIS IS SOMETHING I LOVE
COMPETING AT.
TO GET FOOL THROWN ON TOP OF ME,
IT'S BULL [ BLEEP ] REALLY.
I COULDN'T GET TO THE STAND.
I DON'T TAKE THAT LIGHTLY.
TO ME, IT HAPPENED TO ME LOT OF
TIMES.
OBVIOUSLY, I'VE LEARNED TO LOOK
THE OTHER WAY.
AFTER CERTAIN EXTENT, YOU CAN'T
KEEP LOOKING THE OTHER WAY.
THERE HAS TO BE PENALTIES OR
SOMETHING TO PUT IN PLACE WHERE
FANS CAN'T JUST COME TO